los precios de los productos en los
supermercados son diferentes en
distintas ciudades el papel sanitario en
duluth minnesota cuesta 399 cada paquete
mientras que el papel sanitario en
nuevayork cuesta 8 95 el paquete en
duluth la pasta dental cuesta 195 el
tubo mientras que en nueva yor cuesta
525 cada tubo los datos para este caso
pueden ser codificados en la siguiente
matriz de productos
veamos si esto tiene sentido así que
tienen el precio del papel sanitario en
duluth que es 399 que es esto de aquí y
luego tienen el precio del papel
sanitario en nueva york' que ese 8 95
es este de aquí por lo que esta primera
fila de aquí
esta es la fila del papel sanitario sólo
escribir en p
s para abreviar lo apple
esa es la fila del papel sanitario y
esta primera columna parece ser tu look
mientras que esta segunda columna parece
ser nueva york
nueva york- y veamos si eso funciona
también para los otros datos en duluth
la pasta dental cuesta 195 el tubo por
lo que este dato de aquí está por aquí
por lo que esta parece ser la fila de la
pasta dental dental o pasta dental así
que sólo escribir en
d
así que esta es la fila de la pasta
dental y este es el precio de la pasta
dental en duluth 195 y esta es la pasta
dental en nuevayork 525 y así es como
han ordenado la información en la matriz
cuáles declaraciones de la matriz
mostrada arriba son verdaderas
selecciona todas las que apliquen la
siguiente matriz también puede ocuparse
para contener la misma información que
ge y eso es lo que es interesante de una
matriz lo que tenemos aquí es
esencialmente una encapsulación de los
datos que tenemos en este párrafo de
arriba y es útil porque una computadora
puede hacer uso de estos datos siempre y
cuando sepa qué es lo que estas columnas
y estas filas representan lo primero que
nos preguntan es la siguiente matriz
puede también utilizarse para contener
la misma información así que veamos este
es el precio del papel sanitario en
duluth
este de aquí es el precio del papel
sanitario de nueva york por lo que
tienen exactamente la misma primera fila
digamos que esta es la fila del papel
sanitario
esta sería la columna de blood
y esta sería la columna de nueva york'
pero luego si definimos la matriz de esa
manera ésta tendría que ser la fila de
la pasta dental la fila de la pasta
dental
pero el precio de la pasta dental en
duluth no es de 525 y el precio de la
pasta dental en nueva york' no es de 195
por lo que está no está representando la
misma información que la de arriba no no
puedes ordenar esto al azar ahora
podríamos haberla representado de otras
maneras podrías haber tenido otra
digamos que tienes a la matriz
y podríamos haber escogido hacer algo
como esto donde podríamos haber dicho
bueno quizá este es el quizá está en la
columna de la pasta dental pasta dental
y tal vez esta es la columna del papel
sanitario
y que esta primera fila es nueva york y
la segunda fila es
podríamos haber hecho algo como esto
pasta dental en nueva york que es 525
papel sanitario en nueva york es 895 la
pasta de dientes en duluth es
195 y el papel sanitario en duluth es
399 así que esto hubiera sido la matriz
a que acabo de construir esta si
contiene la misma información porque si
definimos apropiadamente columnas y
filas para representar pasta dental y
papel sanitario en nueva york o en
duluth puedes ordenar esa información
el problema con esta es que no es
consistente esta primera fila nos hace
pensar está bien esta debe de ser la
columna esta debe de ser la columna de
duluth y esta debe de ser la columna de
nueva york y que la segunda fila debe de
ser pasta dental ya que la primera fila
es papel sanitario pero luego vemos que
tiene la información desordenada si
cambian estos dos del lugar
verás que tendrás la misma matriz y que
los datos hubieran sido consistentes así
que definitivamente no diría que esta
matriz contiene la misma información
la segunda columna representa el precio
de la pasta dental en las dos ciudades
así que la segunda columna que es esta
de aquí
y ese no es el precio de la pasta dental
en las dos ciudades esta muestra el
precio de diferentes productos de nueva
york por lo que tampoco la marcaría como
correcta el elemento 21 es igual a 525
así que cuando alguien dice que si
tienes la matriz
y te dan el elemento 2,1
estos son los índices de la fila y de la
columna así que esto es segunda fila y
primer columna por lo que vayamos por la
segunda fila esto es 12 segunda fila y
primera columna está justo ahí por lo
que g 21 no es que 21 no es 5 no es 525
así que tampoco la elegiría como una
opción correcta
un cambio en el precio del papel
sanitario en duluth puede ser
representado con la siguiente matriz por
lo que el papel sanitario en duluth es
esta entrada de nuestra matriz justo ahí
por lo que un cambio en el papel
sanitario en duluth representaría un
cambio en este 399 pero no cambiaron el
399 cambiaron el 9 75 el 9 75
representaría un cambio en el papel
sanitario en nueva york por lo que
tampoco tampoco elegiría esa
por lo que diría que la única respuesta
sería ninguna ninguna de las anteriores